let's go to some gameplay yes we take
you live to our crucible exhibition
they're playing Rumble so it is every
warlock for itself and we're taking a
look at cero's regime so what would you
point out here so I'm not sure what
which style they're running on this one
right now if you want to shoot for a
little bit so we can see that oh yeah so
that's the focus fire style and as you
can see BAM range now to your advantage
yep so you probably want to hang back
and take a little bit more slower paced
combat do a little bit more range with
this guy heavy ammos up how often does a
heavy ammo spawn now and rumble spawns
what after five minutes or five minutes
that once during the game I believe
little R says okay so ever large says
yeah whatever Lars said so here we go we
thought thorn so as you can see you're
doing less damage and that the pulse
disengages a lot sooner than it used to
yeah there were some missed shots that
warlock was fighting the good fight and
all over the place so let's uh so it
still look at a cleaner engagement with
the thought so and so he got two stacks
on there so still stacks but yeah as you
can see the the poison wears off a lot
sooner than it used to so does a really
cool thing where it's still it feels the
same to use that gun you're still
getting the same benefit yep good get
those those poison tix rarely rarely
actually kill the guy now yeah the
victim doesn't feel like they're on
timeout for so long they don't feel like
they have to sit around yeah we're still
in a good run here it eliminates the i
think i believe it was like a two or
three body shot kill that you could get
with those things that that doesn't
happen anymore but you do you still get
the you still get the great benefit of
putting the poison damage over time on
the guy okay and then seeing the damage
numbers tick through walls but also
because it disengages now a little bit
faster is that you sort of get a hint of
where they might be going to disengage
okay but um it doesn't give you exact
positioning anymore as long as that
person keeps disengaging they have a
much stronger chance of getting away so
there's to fight back there's the thorn
that you have it we saw some interesting
things there i saw the thorn shut down a
storm trance there was some you know
some good killstreaks there and so I so
this player should also have decent in
there
a special slot so this is we can look at
the fusion rifle changes here okay
fusion so yeah just across the board
your shot grouping is going to be much
more tighter on these guns now there'll
be a lot more accurate easier to predict
where your burst is gonna land okay cool
what else can we take a look at here
what else here we go here's the last
quarter last word please still be
awesome please still be awesome yeah
easy to hit the guy when you stand still
yeah indeed not so easy when he's
jumping around and punching you
finishing off with a fusion rifle
alright let's see a last word kill just
for all those for all those people out
there with the soul of a cowboy let's
restore the pressure and they're gaining
oh there we go here we go back up on the
horse cowboy back up on that horse
cowboy here you go oh and it what a time
to reload yeah there we go and whoever
that was was a great sport but yeah it's
still a nasty weapon still doing some
work there you go so yeah he'll moves
the needle experiences are purely
anecdotal you know that these encounters
could play in all kinds of different
ways but yeah we've done a lot of play
testing and this is still extremely
combat viable tool okay cool um and so
and then in his special slot we've got
the thousand-yard stare there it is it
was running the short game scope so this
is one of the scopes that has had their
zune pushed out a little bit and there's
an extra two frames of zune time yeah as
he zooming in I am NOT a sniper at all
but it still feels really clumsy to me
in that small hallway here it's a better
suited weapon yeah and then earlier when
he wasn't on the spot we actually saw
some some close-range combat sniping on
Exodus blue with this thing that I think
will will prove that is still possible
it's just a little bit less responsive
okay if you want to get the same
gameplay that you have now yeah you just
got to back up a little bit okay let's
take a look at the spare change so this
is the lowest rate of fire pulse rifle
besides damage on these ones came up a
little bit that you are going to
increase so it's going to be a little
bit more consistent to get a to ship I
should say to burst headshots if you
land all your headshot
in two bursts you could sometimes kill a
guardian depending on his armor stat and
now that's a little bit more common so
again we're encouraging people to aim
for the head and then yeah you clean up
kills and team shooting is going to be a
little bit more effectively okay no to
and and it took and it took a grenade to
stop Bonnie's killstreak there all right
and then let's take a look at so this is
her memory yeah this is the new Queens
assault rifle which is going to be
launching on April 12 and this is a low
rate of fire weapon I believe this
pirkle might actually have focus fire on
it as well so this is going to be super
slow yeah really slowly like your baby
soros but it is it is pretty nasty these
things are pretty effective now so I'm
hoping this this makes some of the auto
rifle players feel like that they have
options aside from doctrine to pass you
should just called a baby Soros because
that sounds adorable baby service you
now just like I got a baby store drinks
Guardian tears not Mel exactly so yeah
these are these are going to be like
hopefully more more people will adopt
these guns I would love to see that all
right and then our last sampling of
weapons here in this loadout so yeah
this is the this is the doctrine of
passing with slightly less damage I
really want to emphasize that it was
slightly less so that if you know if you
get a bead on a target and and you're
pretty much locked in on them yeah
you're still able to melt them pretty
quickly yeah that you know it's when you
get out of the effective range or when
you trying to engage multiple targets or
like like you saw there if you're having
a hard time like actually getting your
your reticle on the target yeah it's
going to be a little bit less lethal and
it's just it's just meant to sort of
like smooth out some of the edge cases
and make this gun a little bit less
dominant but still an effective combat
this has definitely become one of those
polarizing weapons I see dr. don't
passing enter the conversation often
yeah and it's either you know I love
using it and I have it equipped or I
hate getting killed with that gun and
you know we're on a good kill streak
here it's working better up close
although you know the storm caller is a
nasty nasty Beast sure and we'll find
out exactly what is about to befall that
storm caller in just a moment when we
bring a grant out just yet on the couch
and then last but not least is our new
Drake's promise so so yeah the way this
works is very similar to the tracking
perk on rocket launchers yep so as you
aim down the sights you will acquire a
target and then the projectiles will
lock to it so you want to aim it yes
initely want to aim it unlike the rocket
launcher tracking perk there is no audio
so if you're familiar with like truth
and you know you can aim down the sights
and you sort of get that beeping audio
sure it lets you know that you have a
target locked there's nothing like that
for this gun you just have to trust but
it is Greg's promise Greg paying our a
weapons designer he worked on this it
has become Greg's promise he did a great
job that we there has been a little bit
of work on the projectiles because once
we did the new locking stuff it was
extremely extremely good you know now
it's a it's a little bit more balance
that sounds scary I mean when you do
that when you say okay now this gun has
tracking rounds and they work a lot
better or you always kind of like all
right maybe give this to the community
and it's like let's see what happens is
there become the first and last word in
principle combat but you know we'll keep
paying attention we'll keep studying
them we'll look at the you are data
we'll look at you know the usage graphs
and see if it you know takes off like a
rocket the same way might I did when we
brought it forward but if you're playing
in the crucible we are watching you and
we are studying you and we're reading
the things that you're talking about in
the forum
you